foreign
James is in Phoenix hi James how are you
hey dude Ken how you guys doing today
better than we deserve what's up
well my question to you Dave is I have
two cars that I owe a lot of money on
and I'm upside down and I need to get
rid of them so I can start paying off
that I am drowning in debt
it's hard okay car number one is you owe
what on
car number one is a 30 000 or excuse me
thirty one thousand a little over thirty
one thousand okay and what's it worth
uh probably about 18 to 20. where'd you
get that number
I actually got it on the blue
the.com Kelly Blue Book
kellybluebook.com okay and is that a
trade-in value
uh honestly I didn't know I just got
that's the number that they gave me I
didn't really look into it yeah you need
to look into it because the difference
in trading and Private Sales five grand
in this situation
it makes a lot of difference okay so let
because what is that car
uh it's a Volkswagen Tiguan it's uh what
year
uh 2019. okay did you trade a negative
equity car into that deal
uh we traded a a car that was paid off
that just had repeat it was actually a
older T1 and I mean you didn't you
didn't trade a hole into this this whole
so that 18 000 is wrong then okay good
good okay so you you didn't have like a
five thousand dollar hole you were in on
the other car it was paid off so it was
a positive in the trade
yes sir okay all right so uh yeah from
2019 that that Volkswagen did not go
down that far okay so it's probably a 25
000 car twenty four thousand dollar car
something like that so you need seven
Grand to get out of that who do you owe
that money to who's the bank uh Credit
Union First Credit Union okay what about
the next car
next car is a Jeep Renegade 2019 mm-hmm
and I owe 30 a little over 30 000 on it
and what's it supposedly worth
haven't not checked it yet okay all
right so 2019 was a bad year for you on
cars pretty much yeah
um
okay who's that loan with
same same company first good good and
this is Credit Union in your town
yes sir good Phoenix Arizona good okay
so let's pretend you're seven thousand
bucks uh 7 500 upside down on each of
them that's fifteen thousand dollars in
the whole year in correct yes sir and
you have sixty thousand dollars worth of
quick debt and fifteen thousand of it's
not secured
because there's not enough car value to
cover it right yes so you need to go in
person to the credit union sit down with
a credit union manager
and show them what you've got
and here's what you say to him or her
you have a 45 you have forty five
thousand dollars worth of collateral
so effectively you have a fifteen
thousand dollar unsecured loan
Mr Credit Union manager
you following me here
yes sir because you owe 60. the assets
aren't worth but about 45 give or take
so what I would like to propose to you
is that we sell both of these cars and
reduce the loan here by as much as the
cars bring a hundred percent of what the
cars brings is going to come into you
and I'm going to sign a note for the
difference
so when we're finished you'll still have
an unsecured note but you'll have
someone who's much better able to pay it
because it's a much smaller loan
you understand the logic that you're
pitching to this Credit Union manager
I'm writing it down now yeah they
already have a unsecured note we're just
admitting it
that's all we're trying to get them to
do and it reduces your debt from 60 down
to 15 give or take in this scenario and
then you're going to get your couple
thousand dollar garage sale cars to
drive for a little while which is going
to be a big old emotional punch in the
nose from a thirty thousand dollar car
to a one thousand dollar car
you're gonna feel like a poor person
well you are so we're trying to not be
poor anymore that's the idea so we're
trying to reset that